أَصْحَابِي صَاحِبَاتِي عِنْدِي ثَمَّةَ سِرْ
سَأُرِيكُمْ أَدَوَاتَي بَعِنَايَةْ وَحَذَرْ
عَنْدِي فُرْشَاةٌ تَغْسِلْ أَسْنَانَي تَحْمِينِي
مَعَهَا أَنَا أَسْتَعْمِلْ أَنْبُوبَةَ مَعْجُونِي
آَخُذُ بَعْضًا مِنْهُ ِلأُنَظِّفَ أَسْنَانِي
لاَ أَسْتَغْنِى عَنْهُ أُشْرِقُ بِالَّلمَعَانِ
عِنْدِي أَيْضًا مُشْطِي لِجَمَالِي وَبَهَائِي
لاَ أَشْعُرُ بِالسُّخْطِ أو خَوْفٍ وَبُكَاءِ
وَبِهِ شَكْلِي أَجْمَلْ وَبِهِ أَبْدُو أَفْضَلْ
هُوَ بَيْنَ الأَدَوَاتِ بِالفِعْلِ مُؤَثِّرْ
أَصْحَابِي صَاحِبَاتِي عِنْدِي ثَمَّةَ سِرْ
سَأُرِيكُمْ أَدَوَاتَي بَعِنَايَةْ وَحَذَرْ
هَذِى الآَنَ صَابُونَةْ فَواحَةْ بِالعِطْرِ
بِرَغْوَتِهَا وَحَنُونَةْ تُبْعَدُ شَرَّ الضَرَرِ
أُمْسِكُهَا تَنْزَلَقُ أَضْحَكُ هاها مَنْهَا
بِالحَوْضِ وَتَنْطَلِقُ بِصُعُوبَةْ أَقْبِضُهَا
آَهٍ لِشَقَاوَتِهَا تُشْعِرُنِي بِسَعَادَةْ
وَبِكَفِّى لَمْسَتُهَا أَضْحَتْ عِنْدِي عَادَةْ
هِيَ غَالِيَةٌ عِنْدِي تَغْسِلُ وَجْهِى وَيَدِي
تَحْظَى فِي أَدَوَاَتِي بِمَقَامٍ أَكْبَرْ
أَصْحَابِي صَاحِبَاتِي عِنْدِي ثَمَّةَ سِرْ
سَأُرِيكُمْ أَدَوَاتَي بَعِنَايَةْ وَحَذَرْ
عِنْدِي فُوطَةٌ صَغِيرَةْ وَأُخْرَىْ أَكْبَرُ مِنْهَا
لِلْحَمَّامِ كَبِيرَةْ تُجَفِّفُنِي وَبَرَتُهَا
الصُّغْرَى تُسَاعِدُنِي لِوَجْهِي وَيَدِي
تَمْسَحُ كَي تُسْعِدَنِي بِنَظَافَةْ شَخْصِيَةْ
وَبِهَا يَا أَصْحَابِي أَبْدُو حَسَنَ المَظْهَرْ
وَبِشَعْرِى وَثِيَابِي أَجْعَلُ مَامَا تَفْخَرْ
فَأَنَا أُسَاعِدُ نَفْسِى وَأُرَتِّبُ أَشْيَائِي
لاَ أُهْمِلُ أَدَوَاتِي وَبِهَا لا أَسْتَهْتِرْ